I asked my husband what he wanted
for Valentine's Day dinner,
and he said steak and chimichurri.
So I put him on steak duty
while I started all the other stuff.
One of his favorite sauces is chimichurri.
So I got started on chopping up some cilantro
really finely,
then moved on to my parsley.
I like to take a good amount of the stems off,
and then I diced up some garlic,
chilli, and shallot.
I added that to the bowl with my cilantro and parsley.
Squeeze of lemon juice,
some olive oil,
and red wine vinegar.
Also a lot of salt.
Gave that really good mix
and let that sit while he started washing the potatoes.
Lucky can get really specific in his shapes and cuts,
so I decided that he was just in charge of
cutting up all of our fries to get them really uniform.
She did a really good job at well,
I made us an elderberry lime mocktail.
Then he questioned me putting the potatoes in ice water,
but did it anyways.
And I prepped some garlic for the broccolini.
We put all of our food prep out,
and then he dried off the potato.
Or double frying our fries today.
So I gave them their first fry,
set them aside on a wire rack.
Lucky got started on our steaks.
He is always in charge of steaks,
and he also reverse seasons them.
But while those were resting,
I sauteed some broccolini
and some Mushrooms in a ponzu sauce.
And then once our steak was done resting,
I put our fries back in the oil
to get them nice and golden.
I also did this in batches
just to not overcrowd my pot.
And then once they were done,
I sprinkled them with some sea salt,
and then it was time to plate.
Put our fries down.
Broccolini steak
and then topped it with chimichurri.
And lucky said this was a 10 out of 10,
so he had to have another plate after this.